[Music]
hello there it's once again time to look
at the next month of new video game
releases this time it's July and for
some reason July tends to be quite quiet
and that's exactly what this month is
that said there are still a bunch of
great games for every wallet including a
few free experiences I'm Adam your
monthly dad jokes will be at the end of
the video let's do this
starting with the most bizarre game of
2023 EXO Primal from the publisher of
Monster Hunter and Dino Crisis comes a
mix of both unlike either EXO Primal is
a third person shooter in which
space-time vortexes have appeared in the
skies above and through them fall
dinosaurs these living fossils now pose
a real threat to humanity so we suit up
in our exoskeletal armor and take the
fight to the Cretaceous creatures
they're actually in-game weather
forecasts to tell us where the next
dinos will drop it's insane what wasn't
completely apparent to me at first is
that EXO Primal is actually a
competitive PVP shooter as much as it is
against AI the main mode the game offers
is Dino survive where two teams of five
players must race against each other to
complete objectives the XL suits
determine our play style based around
the usual roles of assault tank and
Support classes there is also a story to
get into here time travel is confirmed
as we relive the day the dinosaurs begin
to fall from the sky three years ago can
we stop this from ever happening to do
this we'll be joining the hammerheads
crew and getting to know them be honest
does this sound weird enough to try
releasing on June 14th on PS4 PS5 Xbox
One and series and PC
[Music]
back in 2019 a soulsborne inspired game
released Remnant From the Ashes and now
it's time for Remnant 2. and I'm very
happy they dropped the From the Ashes
part Remnant 2 in the most simplest of
forms is essentially Dark Souls with
guns the first game was solid and well
received but Remnant 2 takes all those
learnings the devs have made and builds
on it will be dual wielding projectiles
alongside standard melee weapons and we
can play through the entire game Solo or
with a friend or even two friends a team
of three Cooperative players is possible
in multiplayer modes here's the big
boast about Remnant 2 expanded
procedural generation in which things
are created on the fly in game from the
world we are walking through to the
enemies that spawn and it said even
story elements are now procedurally
generated and also quest lines too
sounds too good to be true to me but I
can't wait to test it if you'd like to
be the last Bastion of humanity then
Remnant 2 releases on PS5 Xbox series
and PC on July 25th
Ratchet and Clank Rift apart is the
latest PlayStation game to get a part
over to PC this July by the way it's
currently on PS plus extra for those who
are Playstation only the action
platformer was once used to show off the
speed of the ps5's SSD this was one of
the first games to show us the
difference between the last gen and
current gen consoles and although the
rift opening gimmick didn't please
everyone The Lovable characters and
bizarre weapons really did the story of
the last longbacks and his buddy finally
finding someone else out there is really
well told and hey it's a game that lets
you drop a T-Rex from Horizon zero Dawn
on the heads of your enemies what's not
to love Ratchet and Clank Rift apart
will likely be judged primarily on the
quality of the port as the frankly awful
Last of Us Part 1 version for PC a few
months back was a horror show PC fam you
can find this on July 26th
okie dokie let's do some free shizzle
it's not a great month to be fair in
fact I have a video releasing probably
later this week which goes through 20
free-to-play games that legitimately
look really good but right now I'll just
stick to what we have first off Puzzle
Quest 3 Match 3 RPG if you think this
looks like a mobile game well you're
totally right Puzzle Quest 3 has been on
mobile for a long time now the premise
is a role-playing game where we choose
upgrade and evolve a character who
fights against mythical creatures and
other enemies the thing is the combat is
all done in Puzzles rearranging colored
tiles to match 3 to build Mana or
execute high impact attacks then take
the spoils and progress on as this is a
free-to-play game they will try to find
ways to get your money from your wallet
good old micro transactions like always
be aware of these in most if not all
free to play games Puzzle Quest 3 Match
3 RPG is out now on PS4 and PS5 joining
Xbox PC and mobile
[Music]
the next an experience I really can't
class as a game but it sure is
educational this is a light in the
darkness set in France during World War
II and follows the life of a Jewish
Family who go through so much they don't
deserve it's tragic it's painful and
it's designed to never let us forget
what went on back then so it can never
happen again essentially interactive
sections are intercut with video footage
and photographs of the time to really
hit home a light in the darkness takes
around 90 minutes to 2 hours to complete
and actually has achievements and a
platinum trophy on Playstation which
will hopefully get more people to play
it but be warned you'll not feel good
after playing this as an educational
piece of software it does its job very
well out now right now on PlayStation 5
and PC
[Music]
okay before I start crying back to
priced games and a few reduced priced
games one of the most underappreciated
pieces of Kit this year has to be the
psvr too and I admit mine has been
collecting dust for a long time now well
take a look at this reduced price game
synapse retails at 35 that's 35 euros
and 30 quid here in blighty synapse lets
us dual wield brutal Firepower and
telekinesis in a freaky mind-altering VR
action shooter we play as an anti-hero
of socks sent into the Twisted
subconscious of a notorious Enemy of the
State going inside the mind of a foe to
uncover their secrets I think the idea
is great the Aesthetics are amazing and
I'm really hoping the gameplay lives up
to it too synapse is a psvr exclusive
releasing on July 4th next and free two
lost signals a 20 game the original game
came out of nowhere seven years ago an
interactive graphic adventure that was
like playing through an episode of
stranger things which actually makes
sense as the publisher is Netflix we
played as a teenager stuck on a
supernatural Island back then and this
time five years have passed and in oxen
free lost signals we follow the story of
Riley as she returns to her hometown to
investigate mysterious radio signals
that are causing disruptions to the
town's electrical equipment as Riley
delves deeper into the mystery she
uncovers a series of unnatural
occurrings that are tied to a cult-like
group called The parentage and each
decision we make on the way will change
the flow of the story the direction and
even the ending boxing 3 has an art
style that you will even dig right now
or be put off by but if you like it oxen
free do releases on July 12th on
Playstation switch and PC oh and mobile
remember the days when Telltale Games
would put out Banger after Banger in
their episodic Adventure series then
suddenly the company producing them went
under and that brand was finally brought
back to life in 2018 and now they're
ready to do it all over again with the
expanse a Telltale series it turns out
this is a prequel to the long-running
Sci-Fi TV show The expanse the intended
Focus will be understanding the
characters before we met them on the
show and to understand the events that
led them there we'll be watching through
Kamina drummer's life I don't know who
that is I don't watch the show but I'm
sure that meant something to someone all
episodes are guaranteed to release two
weeks after part one and the entire
series is set at 40 which is 30 pounds
in the UK to end a few smaller games
that released this month including the
2D side-scrolling brawler Double Dragon
guide in Rise of the Dragons a homage to
1980s and 90s arcade cabinets that's on
July 27th and we also have guilt a
narrative Adventure game with puzzles
stealth and action set in a fictional
town in the very real state of Maine USA
that's on July 6th and if you're looking
forward to battles of ABM then know that
that's been delayed for another month so
we'll talk about that next time so that
is our month what are you playing I'm
gonna try EXO Primal as it looks so
weird it has my attention and if you're
still here now your reward is bad dad
jokes like this what kind of cheese
doesn't belong to you
nacho cheese let me try another one
which cheese gets a Grizzly out of a
cave
come on bear if you don't know your
cheese those jokes are terrible I'm Adam
you're awesome I'll see you next time